in sharrow a suburb of Sheffield the
cost of living crisis is bearing down
the sharrow community forums a Haven
where people can enjoy a meal for a
pound or keep warm for free
and if the government's promise to cap
energy bills had reassured people like
Lucia whose fuel bill is steadily Rising
then it's abrupt cutting back has left
her dismayed it's not it's not very
promising I have to say
and probably this thing about the energy
bills at the beginning was the only
thing that was like amongst everything
else that we're planning on doing I
thought maybe this is one thing that
could potentially mitigate and help
slightly
all they've done is just massive u-turns
on anything that they've previously said
that we're going to deliver it doesn't
give a lot an awful lot of faith
Sam and Olivia Pearson have seen their
bills rise like everyone else they say
the cap provided a bit of certainty
during an uncertain time how do you feel
about that big plan now being cut back
massively yeah it's a concern because I
don't want to
I didn't want it to get too spring and
suddenly say well we've helped you over
the last winter
now you're on your own it kind of leaves
you in a bit of living though thinking
how are we going to deal with this how
does it make you feel when you see this
political chopping and changing going on
yeah it doesn't make me feel very
confident in the government maybe we
need a new government altogether the
effect of the U-turn could prove costly
when the cap ends in April the average
household bill could soar again to 4 300
pounds and that's worrying people like
Angela Burrows just before coming here I
was driving and I'd literally heard that
that decision and I was like oh my gosh
what is going to happen now I mean
things are bad enough now it's confusing
anxiety provoking
um it kind of builds heightens this
level of fear because people don't know
what's coming next the Cheryl forum is a
charity trying to keep this community
together Rachel helps run it and she's
angry just feel really shocked about if
I'm honest the idea that the government
was doing something it might not have
been the perfect solution but it felt
like something all of a sudden to take
that back
is just galling how is that supposed to
make us trust anybody
you wouldn't accept that in a
relationship why would you accept it
from your government
Cheryl is just one Community struggling
not just with the cost of living but
with the changing and uncertain
political landscape that's impacting on
people's lives here Nick Martin Sky News
Sheffield